- Now, I just explained why
Bill Cosby is going free
because the Pennsylvania Supreme Court
thinks that his Fifth
Amendment rights were violated,
but that doesn't mean that
the district attorney,
Bruce Castor, didn't royally screw up.
The original deal not to prosecute Cosby
was to get him to testify
in the civil suit.
If Cosby wasn't going to be prosecuted,
he could waive his Fifth Amendment rights
and give deposition testimony,
which is under oath in the civil suit.
But the Fifth Amendment is
different in a civil context.
In a criminal trial, you can
never be forced to testify,
but, in a civil trial, you can say
you're not going to testify,
but the judge can take
a negative inference.
So, if that had happened
in the civil suit,
the victim's attorney could
have tried to depose Cosby,
he would have taken his
Fifth Amendment right
and then the judge would say,
"Well, since you're not going to testify,
"we're going to take a negative inference
"and assume that you
probably did the things
"that you were accused of."
And, on top of that, it's not like Cosby
is going to admit guilt
freed from any chance
of criminal prosecution.
He put on his defense in the civil case,
he tried to prevent it
from being successful.
So the Pennsylvania Supreme
Court's decision makes sense,
but Bruce Castor's decision
was a boneheaded move
that probably didn't even
help the victim that much.